If the right to identify with certain arguments has to be earned.
How does one earn it?
How do we truthfully discuss ideas
for which we have not earned it?
That's been wood.
If the right to identify with certain arguments has to be earned,
how does one earn it?
Well,
I think you start by feeling out physiologically what arguments you do have the
right to make and when,
and that's that meditative consultation practice that we talked about earlier.
You have to
pay attention to your words and see if when you utter them,
they put you in a solid place.
That's the line between chaos and order as far as I'm concerned.
And you can test continually that the extensibility of your arguments by doing
so you can,
you can implement more and more sophisticated arguments as you get better and
better at finding that place to stand and take on larger and larger problems.
I guess that's the other part of it is,
you know,
how do you earn the right to,
to,
to an argument,
to a position,
pick a small problem,
one that you think you could solve,
but that's a little more than you can chew.
You know that bite off a little more than you can chew but not too much.
Then see if you can be successful at solving it and then that'll strengthen and
put things in order a little bit.
And then that will entitle you to the use of certain arguments and those
arguments we related to what you've just done.
And then as soon as you've done that,
you'll be a little stronger and more put together and then you can take on a
little bit bigger problem and fix that and then the same thing will happen.
And you just keep doing that.
It's like progressive weightlifting and that,
and you,
you can't truthfully discuss ideas that you haven't yet earned.
You can't,
you have to be quiet,
you have to listen or you have to think about something else.
You have to do something else.
There's lots to do.
You know,
you don't have to engage in arguments that you don't have any right to engage in
when there's all sorts of things you can engage in right in front of you that
would fully engage you,
that would be very useful and that you could contribute to,
you know,
I really liked this idea of incremental improvement.
It's soul,
it's such a good idea.
You look around,
like I have this room that I'm in right now and it's kind of messy.
I know I tell people to keep their room clean and I'd been trying to clean up
this room since like last January,
but I guess because so much chaos is being generated around me in some sense
that some of it's flooded into this room.
The rest of the house is in really good order,
but the residual is still in this room.
But when I come in here,
you know,
I,
I try to spend five minutes to clean up a bit of correspondence or something and
I'm,
I'm definitely making progress.
The room is in much better shape than it was.
Um,
okay.
Don't underestimate the utility of incremental improvement,
and you strengthen yourself by doing that.
And then you can talk about the things that you've actually done,
you know,
in detail in the kind of detail that would convince someone who is skeptical and
knowledgeable that you are someone who knew what they were talking about.
And then if you do that over 10 years,
like you'll,
you'll be solid.
You'll,
the breadth of argumentation that you'll have at your fingertips will vastly
improve.